just to touch about what you just said  there i remember us all being so excited  that we were going to film this sequence  in the boats where we got attacked on  the shoreline by orcs oh yeah yeah and  about three or four days before we were  going to start doing that sequence which  i think was going to be at least a week  if not more  of filming  queenstown was flooded and the sets got  completely washed away and pete just  said no we just won't do it and what's  that like as a producer yeah i mean that  must be slightly  i mean flooded queenstown you can't even  think about it because you it's basic  you have to be sort of addicted to  problem solving yeah  otherwise it's complete madness and you  have to sort of look at it  as opportunity  otherwise you'll just go crazy  [Music]  you're shining bright i'm your boy's the  baby on my pearl